you say are you saying that the United
States doesn't exist therefore there
should be no borders of course time for
the latest installment of change my mind
real conversations on controversial
topics allowing people to rationalize
their own positions this one is kind of
a sequel to build the wall we got a lot
of drive-by yelling we have people husky
as you well know the wall itself and
immigration at large is a hot topic
these days all Americans are hurt by
uncontrolled illegal migration we don't
need a wall is an immorality it's not
who we are as a nation build that wall
build that wall build that wall build
that wall but what do real people think
about president Trump's proposed border
wall and about immigration at large more
importantly what do they know what do
you think we want to hear from you in
the comments below please enjoy hello
take a pardon I was reading counting yes
what's your name Liv Liv Liv you suck
nice to meet you Liv oh sorry Oh Mike
okay I'll make this brief but I have a
couple questions about your experience
personally with it sure but first off
let me kind of preface this what we're
doing here well not debating actually
the point here and I think this doesn't
really happen on college campus a whole
lot is about rationalizing one's
position so I do support not only a wall
but comprehensive immigration not only
what form but enforcement laws that we
currently have on the books I think that
we need secure borders and I think that
that's a strong component to national
security so what part of that do you
disagree with you're welcome to change
my mind I agree that you need a strong
national security because it is
important to the American people people
born here people that immigrated here
legally I think the problem is our
execution okay don't I understand like
living in Texas on my left most of my
life I totally understand what you mean
by we need a physical barrier between
them and us and that's understandable
like you don't know who's over there you
need to assert that America is number
one you serve your country this is like
we need to protect our home about
America number one I just think that a
nation needs yeah I disagree with that
no I agree with that I understand where
you're coming from that no I just think
the idea that a wall will protect that
it's not exactly the most meaningful way
of doing it I think it's more of a
band-aid to a much greater problem
that's our immigration system that
currently okay because it's extremely
difficult to immigrate if you come from
Mexico and it's extremely difficult to
get refugee status and seek asylum in
the US so even though because the big
problem is order our southern borders
the prop no one's like oh no we need a
Canadian border like no one's afraid of
you know why that is out of here because
we don't have it they don't have as much
a high crime rate it's not as violent no
we don't have a problem of illegal
immigration yeah but I think a big part
you mentioned some numbers earlier I
couldn't really hear comes in behind
sure about how people get here most
people do not cross the border
physically on foot like that's not the
main way most people overstay their
visas they come here on planes
not true okay it's not 42% or overstayed
visas
okay okay and the other arrests yeah
across the border I mean enter illegally
I couldn't care less
why does that matter I think the biggest
part for that would be the refugee
status
people that are seeking asylum and that
they are just so desperate that they
don't have a choice okay
are you aware but classifies hearing for
your life correct no okay what is it you
have to be demonstrably oppressed
typically under a regime were
systematically oppressing you for your
faith or race or creed and if you look
at international law it's the nearest
nation that could possibly accept
refugees is required to under those laws
but none of which would have apply of
course - no no no not like cartel
victims - yeah so they would not apply
for that no they wouldn't qualify as a
refugee status and certainly not a
caravan coming from Honduras because
they country yeah yeah
so what do we currently have in place as
far as I understand we have a fence it
is a small fence it does not cover the
entire border yeah there's about seven
800 miles of border that are completely
under that and why due to inactive
politicians for a long time levin
enforce the laws that we have in the
book and have erected the defence wall
whatever you want to call it yeah and by
the way I want to make sure that you
really it's not just about the wall I've
supported all the other comprehensive
forms of immigration but let me ask you
this do we both agree that we need to
enforce we need to know who's here
legally yeah okay and do we both agree
that we need strong borders another
country okay okay execution is where we
differ because you were saying asylum
seekers and you were kind of talking
about which unity people or not
definitely agree
come through legally but when push comes
to pool I can totally understand where
they're coming from I don't think that
those are the people that would become
down food or those will be the people
that come from all the people that we're
trying to keep out so you meet you think
that I don't think refugees asylum
seekers will be kept out because the
people that are most strongly would you
mean like Christians in Syria I will
hear to be talking about more or less I
mean not specifically them because
there's no right well that's a big
problem with you know we don't you're a
big country and we're not necessarily
just protected by the ocean in a very
small border but we're talking about
refugees that would qualify like a
Christian in Syria okay Christians in
Syria
no one's helped them by the way yeah
yeah well how are you aware because I do
keep up a little bit with that I was
thinking but with like as a Jew keep up
with the Jewish situation in the Middle
East and their immigration problems sure
yeah
so you're where the Wold work Israel
erecting the wall and eliminated 99% of
illegal immigration when I was curious
how are you aware that this isn't a
gotcha that specifically Christian
refugees have been taken that's 20
refugees have been taking yeah they're
the most targeted minority in Syria
right now are they not yes yeah because
it's the Muslim majority country right
yeah but less than one percent of the
refugees accepted for Christian really
mm-hmm
yeah they would be asylum seekers they
would be refugees because you're burned
in a cage if you're a Christian yeah and
I would agree in taking those people in
but is it yeah isn't it a little bit odd
that less than some people the number is
under point five percent of the refugees
who are taking in more Christians mainly
you know more aged Muslim males were
taken it interesting I don't think that
would be who that that shouldn't be who
we're aiming to like save if they're
will they be the refugees not someone in
a Honduran Caravan so how do we disagree
on execution how would you you agree
that we need to enforce our current
immigration laws that we need a strong
border I think that system is very very
weak in that we don't it's not staffed
enough there's not enough money going to
immigration to take because it's backed
up like years and years and it's very
difficult to immigrate here illegally so
if you are in a bind to say your uncle
is about to get murdered by the Mexican
drug cartels you're desperate and you
look at this situation that you don't
have the ability to come here on your
own or at least they have the thought
process that they can't because it's so
difficult and there's no there's no like
fast way to do it I think we definitely
need to navigate instead of putting so
much funding into a wall like I can
understand a fence that's fine like the
twenty billion dollar wall is where it's
pushing it why I don't understand the
difference for the fence in a wall the
problem is either one is racist and one
it's okay it's still a drop in the
bucket and the fence is not that much
cheaper but okay how much is the
difference you know well the most
generous estimates have a wall at about
twenty billion dollars and really right
now what they're talking about is five
billion dollars people on it but
Democrats have already agreed to one
point something big in my rounding and
of course they supported building some
kind of a barrier for a very long time
so um why not just build the most
effective barrier possible but if we
just said okay like Donald Trump my
barrier can be partially fenced
partially wall depending on the
topography you okay I think so I just
think that's the idea I think the
imposition beyond the wall I think it
should be maybe I can understand like it
peace of mind I totally get that there's
a fence between me and the bad guys
that's fine
but I think we should instead of putting
all of the money to twenty billion or
the five billion or the one point six
whatever it's not all the money it's
very very little or annual budget is
four trillion yeah it's you so but I
think by doing that we're neglecting the
fact that we do have a broken system for
immigration yeah we do need to support
but the plan is actually to start
enforcing those laws that haven't been
informed okay that's a big part of the
comprehensive plan that Donald Trump is
putting forward in fact enforcing laws
that were put on the books from
rock obama soap seems to me like you
would support a wall a barrier friends
but let's say a hybrid wall fence
whatever works if we also crack down on
those overstay visas if we deported
people who are here illegally yeah I I
agree with that okay good okay so we're
on the same page on that aspect but I
think that the conversation isn't about
immigration anymore it's a it's about or
not the immigration system
it's about keep the bad guys out they're
gonna come get us and they're gonna
steal our women and rape everyone that's
that's a part of the immigration problem
is keeping people out mm-hmm but it's
the biggest issue of course that's the
only way to stop it it's not the biggest
issue is that the most scary issue
because I think the most depending on
how much fear you can bring into the
people it depends on how much they'll
care about this aspect this is kind of
what I've talked about before of
reversed Nirvana fallacy we're gonna say
well something needs to be done we need
some kind of a barrier we need to
enforce the laws that we have we need to
deport people who are here illegally but
because it's created some sort of
ethnocentrism among some people I really
haven't seen it I've never met a
Republican who says the wall needs to
keep brown people out the house people
just say we need to stop the problem of
illegal immigration especially that was
costing hundreds we lost billion dollars
the taxpayer tonight where do we
disagree it seems like as far solutions
you would do all of those things you
just maybe don't like the messaging
which the media is kind of put out there
they're definitely the fear-mongering is
a problem for me among media and then I
think what's going on with the
government right now with the government
shutdown is extremely childish I think
compromises what this country was
founded on and we definitely need to
make a compromise to this yeah who would
you hold responsible for not making a
compromise right now I think they're
both responsible that's fair yeah like I
totally I don't agree with Donald Trump
for saying yeah that's fine and then
totally turning around like three days
later and being like we're shutting the
government down this is over but also I
see the Dimmick
Democrats aren't entirely and they're
against something that they supported
when is Barack Obama they were was
Donald Trump yeah and now he's even made
some compromises right he said okay
we'll extend daca three years right now
what we saw this problem so we can get
the government rolling
I think that the just stubborn like
head-butting in the government right now
is absolutely ridiculous but if he's
made some compromises and they said no
no compromise yeah I would say I would
are I think maybe we disagree but I
would argue they're more responsible and
those concessions have been made so I
guess my issues it doesn't say we
disagree on policy at all no we disagree
on what needs to be done okay so what do
you think needs to be done forgive me
I'm just so final thoughts if you don't
mind no problem I think we should
instead of putting all this money into
the wall I think we should put it into
our immigration system to try and better
the method by which people get you
illegally because right now the system
is very clunky very long it's strenuous
there's not staffed enough not enough
money going in I think we need to take
care of getting people here legally and
then the illegal stuff stop making it
such a fear-mongering event of oh that's
emotion we're talking about we need to
stop the illegal immigration yes but I
think the fear-mongering needs to go
away I think we need to talk about facts
I like your numbers I think it's very
important to have numbers here's a
number that you might consider
fear-mongering illegal immigrants commit
crime disproportionately okay so it's
completely accurate to say that it's
it's a much tougher spilled pill to
swallow to by the way if someone rapes
or killed and the a no business being in
this country in the first place if that
were your sister or your mother or I
don't know your brother by a cartel
being shut up you probably feel like man
that guy had no business thing you're in
the first place and we even do anything
sure we should fix the broken system
right now as far as work visas or being
overstayed people will always break the
law yeah but you're saying we shouldn't
be spending all this money it's a drop
in the bucket we are talking about a
very small amount of money to stop the
people coming here illegally at that
point we can fix the current system and
seems on the books one can't happen
without the other
I think I would be more okay with the
wall if we took the money from say
something that's like defense we have a
ton of money going into defense if we
were to take money put more money
laud into immigration that I think I
would be more okay with the wall and
more spending money on a wall and less
of a like fence okay but what about
getting it and your wealth from like the
welfare program so we have I don't I
think it's more important the national
defense as someone who benefits from it
yes but I am a biased opinion that is a
bias something extremely do you think
that welfare is a legitimate role of
government compared to national defense
um I can see why other people don't
think it is but I personally think is I
think it's very important for a
government to take care of its citizens
constitutionally can you make an
argument that national defense no I
think okay so it's more reliable well we
also understand then adds to the a great
problem we have with a leave integration
right the reason I say that is okay yeah
but they're possible they're benefiting
from the way bears game in a way that
hurts American taxpayers both American
taxpayers who are using welfare and not
using welfare by the way and I think
that's a big difference a lot of people
don't touch on when we talk about being
a nation of immigrants which I
appreciate you didn't bring up so we're
a nation of immigrants delineate we both
are an illegal immigration yeah they
were my there's no well Thursday yeah
but right now you have people who can
enter here completely illegally in
heaven and they're enticed to do so
because of a welfare state okay so I
think we're gonna take money from
anything not take it from a completely
legitimate role of government which is
national defense you can argue that a
border is actually it's a significant
part of National Defense take it from
the welfare state that is enticing them
that is attracting them to begin with
you put that into the wallet but you're
also hurting that legal Americans that
have been here and benefit from it and
need it just to get by stuff like that
they're being hurt more by people coming
here illegally being take it from the
defense then like you said it is a
national difference thing so instead of
putting it directly into the army take
it and put it in an immigration and
or dirty so your so your fiscal
conservative know what does it matter
presenting a five million for a while
you saying what we have to sounds like
you just want to take money from
national defense no but I think then who
cares that we spend five billion in the
world if you're not personal
conservative we spend that's the drop in
the bucket compared to the welfare
program okay fiscal conservative who's
Pro welfare yes okay so some of those
things are little little little
juxtapose yeah I think but I think we
found some common ground you came and
you seem like you were a little a little
bit hot-headed like you thought did you
say no balls I'm gonna say you just got
misgendered yeah that's right off the
bat that's pretty
[Music]
but I no offense if you don't actually
have balls I do disagree well see I
don't really disagree with the fact that
we need enforce our laws okay
of course we do need enforce our laws
but my problem with the wall is just
isn't there a simpler solution to this
broader problem
someone told me before that the reason
why it's being built oh I'm sorry
no okay the reason why I keep bringing
it in because you're pulling away I'm
not gonna hit you up it's on okay
somebody told me that the reason why is
to stop illegal immigration but the fact
is is that most illegal immigration is
from expired visas yeah
so wouldn't it just be a simpler way to
just keep track keep tabs on people who
have visas from overseas and just keep a
look at them instead of creating a five
billion dollar wall that's gonna require
maintenance yeah and that's my well I
appreciate where you're coming from with
that this is where we kind of run into a
common issue with them often on college
campuses so how confident are you that
the majority of illegal immigrants are
just overstayed visas I'm gonna say at
least a good eighty percent eighty
percent confident eighty percent of them
under eight eighty percent of them yeah
I'm very confident it's 40 to 42 it's
forty two percent which means less than
half okay which means the majority of
the illegal immigrants are crossing
through the border are unfettered but
how about this what about doing both um
okay I'd be down for both but my problem
with the wall is it's too expensive
wouldn't it just be easier to create
more checkpoints something like that so
how would you create checkpoints I mean
it would start to be an infrastructure
project but I'm song about the border
you mean yeah I'm just saying we don't
need an entire concrete wall to do that
with the concrete wall you don't have
like nothing's gonna stop somebody from
like chiseling away at the wall but
someone at sitting at like a desk
watching the border they're probably
gonna like you know be able to see yeah
well you know that's all a part of the
immigration plan that that President
Trump is proposing and it's certainly
something I think we find common ground
there that we both think we need more
than just a wall yeah
or just offense whatever want to call
you know I'm not necessarily talking
about a concrete wall along the whole
border I agree with you I would actually
disagree with one point you said it'd be
about five billion the most liberal
estimates in the wall it would cost
about twenty billion plus twenty twenty
billion plus so I'm giving you more than
right that sounds expensive and I would
say that yeah obviously I'm a fiscal
conservative I don't want to waste
taxpayer dollars I assume that you're
probably lining up on the same side of
the coin there but how much do you think
illegal immigrants cost the American
taxpayers every year you've got to be
more concise on that just saying how
much do illegal immigrants cost that
that's encompassing a lot of things you
have to say using social services
abusing the health care system public
education using services that they're
not necessarily paying for because I
don't pay taxes um how much do you think
they burden the american tax you and me
yeah the american taxpayer you IIIi
don't think I'd be able to give a
informed and that's not a trick question
the whole purpose of this I hope I hope
you feel it's been respectful it's not
to do gotcha but I think a lot of people
aren't really informing this issue
illegal immigrants cost on average the
American tax one hundred and sixteen
billion dollars a year mmm so even if
you take those liberal estimates you
becae you said five I said well let's
even go with twenty billion dollars to
build a wall if you look at the the
investment reward ratio there are a
hundred and sixteen billion dollars to
the taxpayers year twenty billion
dollars is kind of a drop in the bucket
but as you said forty two percent are on
x-bar visas forty two percent are net
expired visas so yeah we're getting
close to sixty percent are coming
through yeah wall would help with that
and then of course cracking down on on
visas that have been overstating Donald
Trump has talked about that and
definitely wants to heighten security
and enforce the laws that we have in the
book so a lot of laws that we have
haven't really been enforced as it
relates to visas so uh why don't we do
both
hmm both the wall both the wall are we
still talking at physical wall yeah I've
got to say I think that they're better I
still think that there are better
options like the checkpoint issue I
still think that checkpoints would be
proposing both both yeah there'll be
both it's not gonna be a completely
unprotected wall right now you have
hundreds of miles of completely
unprotected border border between the
United States and Mexico and so we're
talking about is putting up a wall a
fence a barrier as well as having
security as well as also enhancing
cybersecurity cracking down on visas
it's not just about a wall you know I'm
sure it was someone in college you know
it's kind of simplistic as that so if we
do all of that we have a wall we have
those checkpoints we have people there
monitoring the wall and we know that it
would cost twenty billion dollars let's
say and save the American taxpayers 116
billion dollars going forward once we
solve the problem would you be okay with
doing all the above wall plus
checkpoints wall plus checkpoints and
dealing with the the visa issue yeah
well I I still do think that one of the
problems the wall is that a lot of the
area onto the border isn't at all
private property when that all have to
be taken from Americans you're done
eminent domain yeah yeah well here's
what we are talking about and I
understand your concern there we were
talking about an issue of national
security right and putting a ball off
our pop the ball up putting a wall up
around our national border is either
important or it's not I mean I think we
both agreed here that we need to do
something about illegal immigration it
sounds to me like you're not for open
borders okay good so we find common
ground there sounds mean like we both
agree the overstaying visas are a
problem mm-hmm so it sounds to me like
we also both agree we need to stop the
influx of illegal immigrants right now
yeah so if you say well wouldn't a ball
will all be on private property well
wouldn't we need checkpoints let me ask
you this this is kind of where I think
we we we find yourself at a crossroads
it's a bit of a reverse Nirvana fallacy
where it's well it wouldn't really work
entirely so let me ask us what do you
think we should do if not a wall with
heightened border security how do we
solve the problem
ah okay this is kind of a joke
my friend once told me if we had if you
had one person making $15 an hour just
like on a really high chair just
watching everybody for every 10 miles
mm-hmm you could pay that five billion
dollars proposed that could run that
program for 54 years now that's my
entire point why don't we just have
checkpoints while he's thrown along with
some other sort for mysterious why do
you say why do you preface your preset
position there your kind of argument
with this is kind of a joke is it a joke
because then it sounds like you were
saying that's something we should do
well I'm saying that the really high
chair thing as a joke you know it'd be
kind of impractical to have just some
dude on like a hundred foot chair I
think that's kind of like a gross
misunderstanding okay but I think if we
had some some form of modern of the
border I'm not talking about a wall but
you know with today's technology you can
have drones you can have surveillance
you can have I know I appreciate you
guys sticking it out I know it's raining
yeah sorry we didn't bring umbrellas for
all you can have these sorts of there
ways to do the wall there ways to Mar
the border they're wasted okay so let's
go with kind of your your I guess
solution there let's ignore the high
chair but you said having even just
someone being paid $15 an hour at the
border yeah right monitoring it okay are
you sort of are you privy to what goes
on with the Mexican drug cartels pretty
brutal people right I'm aware and
criminals who cross over the border
illegally yeah not the friendliest Bunch
mm-hmm first off where are you going to
find someone to stop those people for
$15 an hour okay and how do you equip
them to stop those people well I'm a
believer in the legal system I just
think that just having somebody
monitoring them having the evidence as
they walk in yeah so you would rather
just have someone at $15 now or watch
them walk in illegally and then deal
with that problem afterward we'll deal
with that problem quickly but we let the
local police departments deal with it
okay so now we're burdening the cost to
local police departments
yes okay as opposed to a federal issue
now we're going to local police
departments but we run into the issue
like we see now sanctuary cities where
we have cities you know in the United
States I'm sure you're familiar with
them you can't deport not only illegal
immigrants but a little immigrants who
have committed subsequent crimes beyond
coming to the country illegally why
should we let these people in why don't
we stop them before they come in you do
realize again that's going to add to the
tax burden like we're talking about it
doesn't seem very realistic well as I
said before we're just gathering
everything so that's all I'm saying
gather evidence I'm not saying that I
did say originally that the Police
Department should detain I'm not saying
that the local city should drop charges
maybe we should get the federal
government after they've come into the
country illegally yes that's a much
lengthier and costlier process than
stopping them from coming in here not to
mention the fact that they don't have
the right to be here in the first place
what's the it's really hard to measure
because again they're off the books
we're not here legally it's in the
millions Millions yeah yes you can see
find some sites that say it's only five
million you can find some sites that say
it's up to 20 million so it's hard to
measure how much does it cost for a
federal federal court to have a federal
court look at the issue well depends
you're talking about where it goes up to
a Supreme Court you know something like
the 9th Circuit Court just like a final
Supreme Court it's actually more
expensive for example to put someone to
death today than it is just to take care
of them the rest their lives in prison
but I think we're getting so far off the
beaten path here that's not our job and
we shouldn't set up a system that allows
for people to commit a crime and then
retroactively Li administer justice and
here's to something else I think you're
not you're not thinking of here you know
the issue that we talked about like daca
anchor babies dreamers the issue there
is the parents have committed a crime
they brought their children here
illegally or they came here illegally
and got pregnant or they were pregnant
when they migrated here illegally and
after that because they've committed a
crime if we have to deport them as
criminals they are separate from the
children they committed the crime right
these incidents wouldn't occur if we
secured the border in the first place so
you're actually talking about adding to
these incidents I don't think it's very
compassionate because you'd be
separating families at that point you'd
be putting them in different prisons it
seems to me that we both agree there
needs to be some kind of an immigration
plan which I appreciate a lot of people
I'm sure we'll sit down and talk about
open borders and how a wall is mean or
racist and you didn't do that I actually
think that simply having a barrier
cracking down on visas making sure that
we know who is in this country and of
course deporting people who are here
illegally who are committing crimes at
the very least is a more feasible
program and I hope that maybe we found
some common ground there and maybe we
agree on some of that no much man
I appreciate it go make fun of your
Bhalla friend really quickly if you
enjoy these authentic unedited types of
conversations do you think of supporting
the program at ladder with better calm
slash mug Club you get access to the
Daily Show as well as a catalogue of
other shows along with this hand etched
girthy mug and of course you support the
program as that's the only way to make
it sustainable because uh tick overlords
don't like us here we go they're more
than welcome to change the change my
mind it's not necessary that I disagree
I guess with the concept of border
security I just think the wall is a
wasteful sim in like that our taxes
paper Wars so like I would believe in
using 21st century technology to enforce
a border like what Republican Wilford
suggested using you know drones using
some of the size and the technology that
Israel has to detect tunnels which would
prevent a lot of the I guess more
dangerous like criminals that are trying
to cross the border you know the drugs
guns
human smuggling and I believe that be
more of a I guess permanent solution
rather than a temporary one that be
symbolic and like I I agree I'm whether
you agree with like more of a
comprehensive reform of immigration yes
your supporter because we do have a lot
of visa overstay people coming through
the waters of the Gulf of Mexico to the
southern states down there in Florida so
I mean I don't necessarily disagree with
you I just think it's a very temporary
it's a very like a temporary American
type of solution where we don't go for
the long term immediately we're always
going through the temporary solution I
think America doesn't go for the
long-term solution not with all our
decisions now with all our decisions but
I'd say you know the country that went
from being oppressed one century go into
a new land only to become the world's
greatest superpower and only superpower
the next that's kind of long ball it is
very long Bowl but it was it might come
from Canada we just kissed the ring of
the the royalty so crude yeah part of
the Commonwealth yes like we have her on
our coins it's very silly but I do I do
appreciate that
we both find common ground here you do
agree that we need comprehensive yes
immigration reform I hate to say reform
because the truth is we haven't enforced
a lot of the laws that are already on
our books as you mentioned with the
visas the visa overstays especially
under Barack Obama these were grossly
violated and I think that needs to be
solved as well I did ask your colleague
here it was mr. Barba and he was
surprised are you aware of kind of how
many illegal immigrants are actually
just here on overstaying their visas
versus crossing the border illegally
that's right now would you kind of do
you have a general gastic a lot of
people think it's most are over these
over states I mean it's hard to exactly
tell cuz I'm not sure even the
government themselves actually know the
number I bet it'd be better for the
state governments have more data on that
right on the federal so that's it's kind
of hard to tell which it's a good it's a
good form of the illegal immigration
it's hard to get accurate statistics
visa overstays a little bit less so
because you can see people who apply for
visas and people who laughter haven't
necessarily been deported properly it's
a it's around 40 percent so you still
have the majority of illegal
immigrations is occurring at the
southern border and the vast majority of
illegal immigrants are coming from a
place like Mexico Honduras El Salvador
of course we just saw Mexico recently
got really
these get these Hondurans out of here
let me ask you this why not do all of
the above again because I believe it's
again it's a temporary solution like
first meeting we need to go so right now
there's no solution right right yeah the
wall is nothing right now I don't know
where this one we're shut down
but we need like a permanent solution so
will we build a wall right we build a
wall the immigration reform you know you
build walls all around even our poorest
Canadian border your throw me they can
just cross it it's really more well
guarded than the southern Burleigh
people don't realize that's because the
Canadian police also do their job but
yeah but I think we have to get to the
root why are they coming here mm-hmm
we can build like you know let's say we
the first wall doesn't work we can build
one ten times harder right the guns
there well people are still gonna be
coming so we need to go to the root of
the problem of why they're coming we to
stabilize their governments and we don't
like the government political lien okay
so we throw overthrow them and then
people have no government and in these
criminals that use the porous border to
put you know take guns from Texas and to
send them south that's another problem
and so then these people are still gonna
be coming and then they're gonna
stabilize in Mexico unless we're gonna
build more walls a huge wall into Mexico
and then just keep going down so neither
wine in New Mexico yes like no we're
only talking about here and it seemed
like you were on board with announcing
like you're kind of zagging as to where
you started said it seemed like you said
we should have saying if he's ok with
with drones with guard something a
little bit more modern than a wall
well now you're saying what the problem
is the root cause is we're destabilizing
these governments let's assume that
that's true ok let's assume that that's
true that it's all America's fault that
we destabilize these regions that were
the ones who screwed up Mexico that's
why they've never gotten it right going
back to the the Mayans and Aztecs the
Incas of Peruvian so let's assume all
that's correct it's all our fault right
why are there still a problem okay but
let's I'm just saying for the sake of
our you must assume that's the case we
still do have a problem with the illegal
immigration
absolutely yeah and we need to solve it
so how do we solve it we get to the root
of the problem we invest in those
countries not just and the companies
that are there the multinational
corporations giving to the governments
that are corrupt are the ones that we
believe are going to keep those
countries stable what are actually
oppressing the people to
if we invest an infrastructure instead
of spending the lens on a wall sending
billions dollars to the Middle East some
places will never go and they won't come
here like unless they come through
playing or you know through visa
overstay through the border or through
the border happens a lot I think that's
really overstated in my opinion and your
opinion okay but if we invest in those
places rather than the Middle East
whether it's just going to get blown up
more war more geopolitical power strokes
with China and Russia if we invest in
Latin America and it kind of a one vote
one Road we have a vision for our
continent yeah we can eliminate the
bomber fleet operations I disagree but a
couple thing are you saying we invest in
these other countries so they do our
building a wall I'm securing our borders
simultaneously or you're saying just
invest in these economies in each
country
I believe it's securing the border I
think of walls is a waste of money I
think we can go into a more permanent
solution ro contemporary what walls work
and again Donald Trump has not proposed
only the wall that's sort of a the
slogan catchphrase he's the first person
to really actively push for the same
kind of comprehensive immigration reform
that Barack Obama pront promised and
Nancy Pelosi agrees I mean I know she
agreed the funding she said we need to
put about a 700-mile fence in the
southern border that's really what he's
asking for right now so let's say okay
we don't do a wall but we do what you
are suggesting drones other methods of
interception seems to me like are you
suggesting doing that as well as
investing are you saying
try investing and don't build a wall I
don't build a border I think we need
absolutely Sakura Porter I've done dated
debate against I just heard wall as
wasteful a wall itself okay I think we
can employ more technology that won't
require the same of investment in the
long term to just maintain a wall and I
think it's very deep even a wall as wall
surrounding error when you look at her
budget but the five billion right now is
a rounding error we have a more trillion
that that's just that I mean you can
when you start using rounding errors is
the same concept a lot of Democrats use
to keep us and Republicans to keep
spending money but now when you look at
the illegal immigrants who cost the
American taxpayers and 116 billion
dollars per year so if a wall would work
and there's a lot of it
to suggest that it would work it is real
just directed a well 99% of illegal
immigration stuff I want to save a lot
of problems I mean you solve immigration
then you have missiles being shot across
the border and the tunnels you created a
tunnel problem is really well is really
bad for is it right yeah if we have
Mexicans firing rockets into our into
our churches I think we'll have a
problem but I don't foresee that
happening anytime soon
second we hear of mariachi band yellow
Allahu Akbar I'll duck for cover and
maybe we'll will go on that that pathway
let me ask you this you say invest in
these countries I'm curious as to how we
would do that do you mean invest in
companies and invest enough governments
not even governments okay so how do we
invest in their infrastructure we just I
think we need more of a cooperation
we've done what we did with Germany and
after World War two and a lot of those
countries whether we forget a lot of
these countries in Latin America are our
allies what regardless whether we're
paying then we prop them up or trade
agreements right if we prop up these
countries show the mutual respect
as fellow continental Americans I think
we can solve this problem how would we
invest in them as much I don't I'm not a
politician sir well you suggested as a
solution I'm not trying to catch you or
anything I mean we invest in roads
invest in education clean water
directors having clean water problem if
we also check some of our companies that
are over there that are exploiting these
people and taking their water supply
taking their clean water destroying
their national environments where they
need to Pharmacy you just said you said
earlier you weren't doing this but your
honor in implicating the United States
as though it we are the problem they're
not people are leaving because we're
stealing their water I'm not saying it's
the United States as a holistic but
certain actors so we invest in their
roads we invest in facility in other
words we'd have to give that to their
government not necessarily and maybe we
haven't done that in the Middle East and
we didn't do that in Germany and we
didn't did a lot of countries that we've
invested in okay so how will we do this
here in Mexico we used we aren't where
our allies we can work together and do
things we've built things together we've
built things so again but I think
something that's kind of important you
mentioned the destabilizing a lot of
these regions in these countries mm-hmm
well how do we do that
I mean there's by invest they say like
for an infrastructure and trying to bet
on a certain team right that's how Isis
was created I agree with you I'm more of
a non interventionist but if you invest
now in New Mexico
anytime you're investing you're
investing with somebody yes so it's it's
ironic that you say we need to invest in
these countries and then also talk about
how the whole reason that they're
destabilized is because of prior
investment and I don't think that solves
a problem and I know you said you're not
a politician of an open border right now
hundreds of miles of open border which
costs the American taxpayers hundreds of
billions of dollars every year well we
benefit from that from cheap labor I
mean maybe not necessarily you're
benefiting or anyone in this crowd is
benefit but we have lots of very rich
people that are benefiting from
extremely cheap labor you can continue
the only reason they're here too is
because there's work that's reason
they're in this country then that's
other probably need to get to the root
of we to be maybe having Universal a
verified maybe we need to have all these
corporations be like you need to go
through your employees gokul's working
for you and I agree in cracking down on
employers who are hiring illegal
immigrants and that's why there's lots
of work we benefit from cheap food
that's underpriced because we're used
under labor under paid labor so I think
there's a lot more benefits to that cost
where it comes out almost even well the
analysis would show that it's not it
cost the American tech and you might be
talking about corporations it's kind of
interesting that you bring that up so
you think it's okay if corporations are
benefiting from cheap labor because the
American taxpayer the average citizen is
not they're the ones footing the bill
yeah I don't think it's right I don't
think so then I guess we would agree in
securing the border by whatever means
there you're talking I think a wall is
an important component to that cracking
down on the overstaying visas and
deporting people who are here illegally
we're both agree on that I think other
than deportation for whether we deport
people who are here working and making
money
why wouldn't we use that as a
money-making opportunity because they
came here illegally they broke the law
I mean was it their fault that they
broke the borrower's at our form of
enforcing them that's that's where I say
their boat isn't it their fall to feed
their followers
yeah it's their fault just like if we go
into that library right now and steal a
book and the security guard doesn't see
it sound security guards fall it's your
fault would be the library's fault oh no
I mean if there's an announcement of
losses are necessarily a level yes
there's a law you broke it you just
didn't get caught and then if they saw
you and your physical science class and
hauled you out in cuffs and said hey you
stole a book they'd be well within the
rights to do so yes I do believe it
person knowingly breaking the law is
breaking the law and that person should
be deported especially if someone's
committing subsequent crimes in the ad
with sanctuary cities we can't even
deport people who've come here when we
say committed illegal immigrants
committing crimes it's redundant but I'm
talking about subsequent crimes in
addition to right yeah migrating here
illegally
we can't even deport some of those
people they're in our prisons right now
I think it's I think is wrong where we
can't deport these we are committing
crimes that are being violent because
that is a big place and you should be
putting criminals that should be there
in those prisons rather than people that
shouldn't be here like legally so you
would agree with deporting criminals who
are in our prisons or here illegally
absolutely I don't think we should be
holding violent uh undocumented
immigrants in our prisons I completely
agree with you and by the way I think
that's an important point as we talk
about the government shutdown there's a
lot of blame has been placed around when
we talk about like I said a rounding
error we talked about five billion the
Democrats have agreed to one point
something billion and Donald Trump once
I think the five point one or five point
seven billion
along with comprehensive immigration
reform he's offered to extend the daca
three years but you're talking very
solution that should be permanent
I don't believe it should be permanently
should have a problem again right now
he's trying to get the government
started back up whereas if you look at
the current Democratic Party they don't
believe the policy is that you can't
even deport illegal immigrants who are
committing crimes here right now and
that's very new policy by the way it's
only happened under a president Trump
when you look at how the
interacted with President Obama and even
going back to Clinton it was a very very
common solution to create a wall and of
course to deport people who are here
illegally committing crimes for some
reason now there's no compromise on that
and I think maybe you and I if we were
sitting down to have a little bit a
little bit more of a productive solution
to hopefully stopping the government
shutdown than the current democratic
party with Donald Trump but I think we
line up on more than we then we disagree
all right I appreciate it mr. Barr
yes thank you very much sir I appreciate
it
[Music]
I think a tear down the wall down on the
wall tear down the wall
cool story bro okay yeah so I'm an
anarcho-capitalist which means that I
favor the doctor in that private
property is sacrosanct the rule of
contract two synchros saying therefore
the United States as a the United States
government in that it presupposes that
everything everybody that's in its
borders they've a right to tax they have
a right to basically do ever the heck
that institution may have to do with
what are you saying are you saying that
the United States doesn't exist
therefore there should be no borders of
course okay yeah yeah disagree with that
so I what would you see in the place of
the United States you would rather have
a Native American ethnos snake well no
obviously not that's obviously not what
I mean however okay so let me go back
here huh native if you want to talk
about I mean I think that the
reparations argument is something
totally different I'm not talking right
no I know but I mean what I'm coming
from is that what gives the United
States government the ability to do
whatever it whatever it wants to do I
mean and you yeah of course do you
believe that countries exist no because
they're not done through contracts okay
so you don't believe that any countries
exist oh no I don't deport I mean okay
ton to agree on their attrition I can't
talk about securing a country if you
don't think countries are a thing I just
disagree with you
okay okay Steven okay crazy person let's
go one more if you disagree you're more
than welcome to change my mind I see you
have a sign here so assuming it kind of
can guess where you're coming like this
is that like people the government you
know the right-wing sort of that
supports this building of the wall
they are often trying to deport people
who come in seeking refuge and and
seeking shelter and put them back to the
place where over for assault I think we
can hopefully agree that that completely
messes with the person's life if you
come in and then are pushed back out to
a system that you tried to get away from
no no you don't you don't think that's
you don't think that's how and I think I
think no I it's not that I wouldn't say
it's harmful to them but use the term
seeking asylum or refugees there's a
clear definition what constitutes a
refugee well someone who is struggling
for the government struggling from due
to the government in their own country
and then is coming in seeking a better
experience in America because it's not
what a refugee is you don't think that's
sort of how the legal definition I think
it's important to note have you been
taught this in school what a refugee is
what is required for someone to be a
refugee and what the protocol is to deal
with refugees nothing that rigid now
okay it's international law so it is
specifically somebody who is being
persecuted for their religion color
creed by the government facing physical
bodily arm usually death from their
government
and so it is the duty of the nearest
country nearest country possible to take
those people in so for example
Christians from Syria would be refugee
they're burned alive by Isis and cages
where those would be refugees right
people who think that America is better
than their country would not be refugees
so just because they don't qualify for
this legal definitions international law
definition refugee you don't think they
should be granted granted shelter or or
just be allowed to be here because
they're seeking a better life is that
what I'm
is that what I'm understanding correctly
okay I don't think that it's a
fundamental birthright to be an American
citizen unless you're born in the United
States or immigrated here legally took a
naturalization oh okay and what's wrong
with that what's wrong with coming here
and even if you came here legally is
there it do you believe in the idea that
people who are against seeking a better
life people who are you know very much
struggling perhaps dying or or would die
in indigo would come up here and so
you're saying that's like that it's not
just that it's not it right but is that
what is the harm and if coming here you
know I've heard a lot of rhetoric about
the economy but like I guess I just
don't understand the idea of this wolf
they are people just like any American
born citizen is so why can't they get
will the economy well I can't luckily
Drive job a couple of things they are
not people just like any American born
citizen and that they are not citizens
of this country just like I'm not a
citizen of Mexico in Mexico there are
certain rights are not afforded to me as
a majority to this in fact even the
right to own waterfront property is an
issue they have much more strict
immigration but as for your first
question now first off it doesn't
address the fact that it's not a human
right to be a citizen of any country
that you want to be a citizen and
where's the harm one unless a couple of
things legal immigrants people who've
been waiting trying to get to this
country illegally people who've played
by the rules people who obeyed the law
they get hurt because if an overburdened
immigration system the economy hundred
and sixteen billion one hundred and
sixteen billion dollars footer to the
taxpayers each year and a
disproportionate amount of crime
committed by illegal immigrants
those would be three reasons okay so I'm
kind of what I'm talking particularly
about reasons one and three so reason
reason three kind of jumped out to me
it's certainly my opinion that if
they're criminals and they should be
persecuted you know put put into the
justice system whatever like I am NOT a
budding deported sure because they
because they they came here seeking a
better life and then just ruin that by
being criminals I understand that that
I'm not some of them aren't seeing a
better life and I'm not supporting
criminals
of course I'm supporting people who are
honestly struggling in their own country
and trying to come here but I didn't I
didn't say they were supporting
criminals you said what is the harm and
just allowing anyone to come here
legally or illegally and I gave you
three reasons I didn't say they are all
criminals and I don't believe that you
support criminals listen I don't think
you're a monster I hope you don't think
I'm a monster
what I am saying there's a
disproportionate amount of crime
committed by illegal immigrants okay
it harms legal immigrants because it
over burdens our system and of course it
is a harm to the American tax credit to
the tune of depending on you ask over a
hundred billion dollars a year those are
three reasons I want to stay with that
I'm not saying that you support
criminals I would not did it now another
thing you're saying it hurts fuel
immigrants are trying to come here
legally which by the way I hope is
difficult but the I don't see how
undocumented immigrants who are not in
the system they're not on the books
coming in here hurts people who are
legally coming here because if they're
undocumented they're not being put into
a queue it's not like oh we're full now
I don't understand I just described
exactly what it is that they're that
there's a limited capacity how a meeting
comes in there's a limited capacity as
to how many we're gonna have in a
country especially when you have people
who takes us to number two right are a
net burdens on the American taxpayer it
costs a lot of money to have a legal
immigration system
plus a lot of money table to monitor to
be able to approve these to get people
this country legally when you have
higher than sixteen billion dollars
being great to the American taxpayer and
potentially they can go to other other
services or other legitimate roles of
government because of illegal
immigration
it harms everybody that seems like a
self-fulfilling prophecy there you're
talking about how the there's a huge
burden on taxpayers because of the
immigration system in the visas and
everything no no because of illegal
immigrants only has a villa guards
because of Ely one because of illegal
immigrants six close to five hundred and
sixteen billion dollars a year yes and
and where is that figure coming from
what is art are they where's the cost I
don't I guess they don't understand if
somebody's coming here trying to work a
job for love life where's the where's
those where's the cost of the government
from that wealthy yep one of them
welfare not paying taxes using the
social services the safety net welfare
state that we have right now without
paying into it and of course things like
using emergency rooms and they can't
bill you because you're so scary number
so it's one hundred and sixteen billion
let's assume I'm off by twenty billion
but he asked for three reasons are those
three reasons reason enough to say okay
and we have a problems the illegal
immigration will not my not my opinion
okay all right I mean you're kidding
feel sure but let me ask you this do you
believe that the United States needs to
have a border
we're talking about like Oh like a wall
or a fence or a gate or something right
here you're not talking about the
ability or to prevent people from coming
in unless we invite them in I do not
think that there should be a border in
that sense you don't I do not okay so
you don't believe in countries I like I
said I believe in the line if you were
to draw a line between America in Mexico
that's fine that's on a map but I'm
saying if there is nothing but just a
field of grass there I think that's fine
so much because it's unprotected and
there's no wall someone should just be
able to walk across it what's the idea
of protecting a plot of land that is I
mean okay like every country since the
beginning of time as headquarters and as
had a monitoring system to make sure
that people who are in the confines of
their country are there legally sure I'm
fairly sure there's some ones in Europe
not and they have very open borders so
every time I see here feeding you know
maybe Native Americans that really
believe in a personal the concept of
personal property but the United States
isn't one of those nations we are a
nation with a system of laws we do have
a system for legal immigration and you
are to abide by that current system so
let me ask you this you're against the
wall I see you have a sign here that
says you know human is illegal yes so I
don't really know that we're gonna find
a whole lot of common ground because I
do I do believe in words and I do
believe that people should come here
legally
you don't know human is illegal explain
to me your point of view what would you
do well it's a I guess it's like a more
like a moral I mean like because it you
know again if you're if you are
struggling you know you're essentially
being I don't know how to say it but
like in government in Mexico you know
the government makes things difficult
for these people who want to immigrate
and so it's like you're you're in it's
probably going between a rock and a hard
place right because you're you're trying
to to enter and have a better life but
you come from a place of difficulty and
then
you know you come to a place where
people are having a good time or at
least you know relatively and in a
country to a superior country I don't
know if I go that far but that's what
you're describing an inferior and if
you're a government to a superior
government well I'll say but but
basically basically coming into the
country seeking what you know by the way
me advertises the American jury so you
would say superior government government
what makes it scarier spirit economy
about is economy better I will make it
superior because I'm trying to avoid
this racist rhetoric that people have
when they start out like superior
countries and everything like that's
kind of as you just described people
wanting to leave a country that is
clearly inferior in search of a bet if
someone is leaving one country in search
of a better life and they say I'm going
to America how would you define that
country if not superior a place of
perhaps greater opportunity but to say
superior you believe it's reaching
superior is an all-encompassing term you
see yeah like you know that our country
but you said superior government okay
what makes it a superior government I'm
just using your words here I think I'm
gonna go back on government because I
don't think I'm informed enough about
the Mexican American government to make
that comparison but econ superior
economy a severe economy why is the
American economy superior okay well just
a good sample B GDP and GB per capita
you know meaning income I mean I guess I
don't really know like why the stevie
question because you're talking about
you're saying that people have a
fundamental right to come here you'll
want to avoid using the word superior
but you're saying because people seem to
have a better time there seems to be
better there's a reason that they're
coming here I need you the Ameri Huey to
ok the American dream that's what that's
what we market it as that's like right
that's like part of the pride of our
nation just a Pyrrhic Onam a and the
American dream
yes
okay that's not I just wanna make sure
that's not considered racist right that
is not consider is why do you think the
American economy is so superior to say
Mexico well I don't know I mean that's a
very multi-faceted question
I assure you well I mean like that
simple are we I compared to Mexico or we
have free enterprise economy everything
so okay so there's one compared to
Mexico are we a nation with an intron
Constitution and fundamental inalienable
rights yes so the same laws in place
that make by your own words a better
economy you said government knocked off
a better economy
a place that's more desirable are also
the same laws that say people have to
come here legally you can't have one
without the other and what you are
suggesting is to allow people who are
leaving an inferior economy I would also
argue government country culture in
general Mexico that's why they're
leaving your suggestions to allow people
to come here off of the books and take
advantage of a current welfare state
that we have all not necessarily
contribute but without saying that the
United States is superior it's so
desirable by your own words people would
risk death to come over here but it
would be racist to say it's superior
right because if you're a country you
type the Mississippi but that's your
that's I'm just want to make sure you
understand that the confliction I'm
sorry would you say that that Americans
is superior country to Mexico
yes all right well that's that's here
that's your word that's your opinion
I was only human beings can be illegal
also is that they can be in a country
illegally there's something you says to
be talking I can't go back on for a
minute you said that the same laws that
the same laws that make it difficult for
them to come in is or difficult for them
to stay here without going through the
rigid legal process what I'm saying is
the same thing that makes America a more
desirable place you know America more
desirable place it's the same reason
they need to enter this country legally
because we have a rule of law that needs
to be enforced it's from the same paper
I mean
in constitutions but the Cotten's
there's no evidence or at least I would
think there's evidence at that
particular part of the Constitution I
think it's a paper not the same not the
same sentence not the same paragraph
that makes that makes the economy so
great that makes our nation great why do
you believe our nation was great that's
not really topic of discussion here
because so more people want to come to
United States if anywhere else in the
world well why do you think the United
States is so great then I guess they go
back to a set the economy the economy is
great
the economy is great the economies is
doing okay and why do you think that I
don't know I mean again that's a very
multi beste question like when the
economy is fine in Canada sure so then
Canada's doesn't order Mexico so people
who come from I'm sure they'd be just as
do you think it's just think if you can
teleport to Canada what do you mean do
you think it's just the economy I don't
know what you're going for here as long
as you've talked about the great lengths
that people will go to to get to this
country and I agree with you but you
said you don't to use a superior
rhetoric because for some reason that's
racially charged by the way well I mean
okay we're doing a lot of
ring-around-the-rosie you're an electric
razor on a point where you're saying
superior in every way but you don't want
to use the word superior how is it
racial each others to say because there
are aspects of America that are superior
to aspects of other countries but to say
a country is superior is evoking
rhetoric such as like you know Germany
World War two right so it's not about
how is it not because they were saying a
race is superior we are saying a country
disappear it was a set of ideal must a
set of laws is superior by the way a lot
of different races here in the United
States they would all be included in the
superior I don't think is an apt
comparison yes why is it racially
charged rhetoric to say that America's
he as a superior country
well I mean I'm not sure it particularly
matters that there are so many different
different races here when you know you
have like America still being
predominantly white so I mean it's still
family white nation and and I mean like
it's certainly much more diverse life in
most other countries fair fair and I am
all for diversity I'm wearing a shirt
that says diversity okay I'm all about
diversity in eight countries and I think
that's a good thing but we are still
predominately white and we still have a
disproportionate Viper white
representation in government and etc etc
is that why you want more illegal
immigration because you like to see us
less white no because I I was coming
back to the point that was really making
is they're they're struggling they're
trying to to escape that and come here
and and live the American dream that we
mark it and then they're just told you
need you need to get the heck back to
Mexico I mean that's where does that
like what's that distance Mexico know
what is the what is the life of a person
who who is again perhaps on the verge of
death but we could just say verge of
extreme poverty very reasonable that we
don't even have laws do you think that a
wall or border it sounds like it you
said that saying America's the superior
country is racially charged it is do you
think the name is that why you're
against my name a wall on the border
I believe what that's a racially charged
issue I've heard a lot of people know
it's more out of sympathy for the people
who are who are trying to come here I
think that they are so so often vilified
and demonized that you know people don't
again they don't have that let's talk
about only what you and I are talking
about here okay vilify to demonize
anyone I have compassion for these
people we're saying that they're back in
Mexico which is a which is a tortured
existence
that's identifying or demonizing them I
can be compassionate we say if we still
are a country of laws that you have to
follow so do you consider myself leader
struggling and they didn't disturb you
when we have the resources to support
them we don't let me ask you this yet
what building is that over there that is
a library okay that's a library yeah um
you know what their hours are actually
their 24 hours actually really they are
I think past 11 you have a student hard
to get in okay yeah so you have to prove
that your student yes
what happens if you're not a pseudonym
card 411 you don't enter I'm not sure
what your point is here precisely but
that that racially-charged that is not
very discriminatory this is such a straw
man hold on that's not this is this is
why versus why do we have yes no I'm
very comfortable why does the library
have the right to say no matter is
served yeah yeah skill doesn't matter
this is the University right before they
can say you have to be a student to use
these services to be here after these
hours that's appropriate for a country
well well no because okay well first of
all people chose to come here that
there's a big matter element of choice
people don't choose to be born into
Mexico according to America I mean it's
kind of interesting like how people
think people fundamentally deserve these
things but that's kangan so it's
basically like people pay tuition to
come here and therefore they they sort
of have that and again they choose to
come here and so that's the difference
kind of like paying taxes but you are
not but so nobody chooses to be bored
and they sort of live their lives living
a life is different than having a
college experience college experience
I'm simply using the idea of a barrier
there again unless you're contributing
here in school enough some time
contributing taxpaying American citizens
by the way legal immigrants I'm
concluding here that's we asked again
we're going back to three answers what
harm does it cost that's not gonna cause
us to legal immigrants just like if
someone came here and rented out all the
books and they weren't as do
I don't see what's wrong with having a
key card to prove that you are a
contributing member of this content but
I also don't think there's anything
wrong with saying the United States is
superior to Mexico so I don't really
know that I don't I think there's
cognitive dissonance there if you're
saying I can see that were superior to
Mexico but no human is illegal because
so many people are willing to die to
come over here I think we need to be
honest about where we're lining up the
United States is a better country that's
why people want to come here I'm
compassionate because I'm honest about
that but you still need to sign the
guestbook on the way and if we don't
agree that there need to be borders
don't think we can find much
I like how you freeze it I just signed
the guestbook on the way and like it's
that simple
right like you can just go through the
process of becoming a citizen weekly
which is again difficult and get a good
students you know do okay we'll do you
agree with perhaps easing up on that a
little bit making it easier for I don't
you come in Legally okay I don't and
another point I know this is kind of
jumping all right but why we do have to
get going here run out but go ahead all
right
illegal immigrants you're saying they
don't contribute anything is is that is
that what you're saying that they just
come here and all they do is just they
cannot see anything I'm not saying all
early bloomers but illegal immigrants as
a whole are a net burden on the American
taxpayer absolutely
and do you think that there's something
maybe we could do to help change that
instead of yes instead of instead of
deporting them or securing the border no
I think that's a solution you think
that's the solution we try that first
immensely what else we got yeah and plug
the hole just like a mana sinking ship
plug the hole plug the gaps in the fence
unfortunate in that we have make sure
that we have border security and yeah I
think the port people who are here
illegally yeah that's what I believe
unfortunately I think we're not going to
find common ground because I'm coming
from a place of compassion and I'm
talking about sort of coming from and
again I was going to come back to saying
like well I think passion for these
people play on compassion I don't think
that being compassion means giving
somebody everything they want and I have
a lot of compassion for legal immigrants
to this country even had someone who
worked for me who was a legal immigrant
whose visa ran out he had to leave and
add compassion because that guy was a
hard worker we've had several people who
actually worked from Germany we have
some beer right now and that compassion
for them so I think for you to assume
that you have the moral high ground on
compassion just because you only have a
fundamental worldview yet as to how to
solve the problem I think they're not
affording me the same luxury up for you
and then I assume you want to solve the
problem and you care about people you're
just wrong in your solution to say that
you're coming from a place of compassion
assuming that I'm not the best way to
have a conversation but I understand why
you would think that so I still
appreciate I still appreciate that I
meet you thank you very much sir if I
appreciate it there you have it some
surprising common ground found some
yelling you know that countries aren't a
thing but it was mostly productive we
hope you enjoyed this installment please
support it a lot of credit at calm slash
mug Club and we'll see you next time
well I won't see you but you'll watch me
here
[Music]